i'll tell you what man we get to the
point where we got star trek replicators
can't wait then i'm not you then then
i'll i'll listen to your argument about
you know free resources if if if we
invent star trek style replicators where
you could walk up and go
you know computer double cheeseburger
extra bacon and the side of cheap potato
fries with uh you know a large coke
and then boof it just appears and we
have that
but they're withholding it from the
people i will protest
yeah i will demand my replicator yeah
i'll say hey no i want
but we're not there that's not reality
that's science fiction
so if there's a finite amount of
resources to go around then we allocate
them in this way i do think we're
getting to a point though
the reason we're seeing this is because
we actually have the resources to
sustain people who do nothing
these antiva people literally do nothing
their work is
organizing organizing what yeah chaos
this makes no sense
right yes so if people were occupied
what's the saying idle hands the devil's
playground is that it
good that's the same so they have
nothing to do they're bored and because
of this they live in this fantasy world
so we are getting to this point where it
is becoming easier and easier to produce
food
which keeps people sustained and we
actually now start starting to have fat
homeless people well that's if the
wheels of society keep rolling though
right you know which
they i don't know if you notice their
economy has come to a big huge
halt lately i got no problem farming
neither do i i
i i hunting for that matter a good a
good day of hard work is obviously no
problem for me
that's true you don't ever stop working
nope 16 hours a day every day no days
off
i love chopping wood i have yeah man we
had a bunch of wood in the back adam we
just got for fun and go chop it
i i'll tell you what man if if if we
enter a post-apocalyptic you know
world i'd have no problem waking up at
the crack of dawn and going and tending
to the fresh crops and the animals
it'd be it'd be a lot of fun these
people however no they're gonna cry
well and they're they're claiming
they're going to the the sturgis rally
yeah right and uh i mean they have
thousands of people show up
i mean and they're bikers and i think
they don't mess around but those guys
are going to be disciplined
they're not the people that show up or
none of the sturgis guys yeah
biker dudes yeah they're they are
they're they're dude they know what
they're doing
it's like you don't show up there and
try to do something though
it's like the saying about you know when
you're at a bar
the guy who's talking a lot of smack is
not the guy you want to worry about it's
a guy minding his
own business who's quiet and chilling
yeah there's going to be a lot of
i'm sure you'll get some rowdy dudes at
like a sturgis rally who will like
definitely throw down immediately
i'm sure most of these guys are going to
be like little boy this is not the time
and place
you can go out that way because you
don't you do not understand they don't
understand these
people they don't get it they don't they
live in a video game i would love
i would love this and i've actually
offered a lot of people this a lot of
these lefties
an opportunity to go to a place that
they think you know
that they've been concerned about to
actually experience and talk to people
and they never take the offer like i'm i
know a dude in chicago who's always
complaining and like you know pro black
lives matter and all stuff
and i was like how would you like
funding
to go and shoot a video in one of these
neighborhoods and talk to the locals
about how they feel about what's going
on
gone in two seconds you know why why
they live in chicago they know what
these neighborhoods are really like yep
and they know that they're that there's
that they're not welcome
the things they they claim are not true
i've i offered one guy
one time i said how would you like to go
and actually cover
some news in israel like legit do some
interviews
gone you know why because they know all
of the complaints they have
once they actually go on the ground in
israel oh a bunch of regular people are
going to talk to them about the conflict
and the complexities
and their narrative and extremism falls
apart
they never want to actually do it it's
not just that though a lot of these
people
talk big they're all tough and then i'll
say like how would you like to go on a
camping trip
gone but i like living in the city with
all these free and easy things that are
readily available to me yep think about
this way this is what's crazy
imagine living in the middle of nowhere
you know 10 000 years ago
where's your water coming from you would
know how
you were alive how are you getting a
thousand years ago but no no let's say
right now you got transported boom ten
thousand years in the past
you gotta find water okay i know where a
stream is once you find it
all right how do you clean it you got to
make fire
well no ten thousand years ago our bi
the biomes in our belly would never
be able to handle the water that we
would be used to i'm just saying you
right now oh oh
i'm physically transported right oh man
there's no opportunity to find a city
you've got to survive the reason i'm
saying this is the people right now
don't realize
going into the bathroom and turning a
knob and fresh clean water coming out
is the luxury among luxuries
and and your your excrement goes away
pooping in the toilet where does it go
where does the poop go
you don't have to worry about it that's
the world you no digging holes
no burying it yeah but here's what
people don't also don't realize
is that you back in the day everything
you did would leave ascent there are
predators
yeah so you you if any one of these
people were just dropped in the middle
of like you know the yukon territory or
something
tundra as far as i can see they'd be
like wow
i really am wealthy with all of the
gifts of modern
society yeah it's true i i actually am a
big fan of those
those living in the world in the
wilderness shows yeah man you ever watch
uh uh
ancient technology oh yeah that's
awesome he like makes a mud hut
yep any any and like he gets clay and he
sets a fire he created a stove to like
he
that dude is amazing those are awesome
videos so here's the thing
i love that stuff yep i love i love
building i love
planning i love solving puzzles i love
you know i love working hard on whatever
i have to do to make
something succeed these people don't
they're the opposite they're the
inversion that's true
they go out and they destroy and they
complain this is the world that
they think is the norm it's not
it's not it's what i say a lot about
like the bridges in new york
they don't realize there's what are we
got the brooklyn bridge manhattan bridge
the williamsburg bridge the
queensborough bridge washington prison
tappan zeev verrazzano yeah man you got
a lot of bridge you got the battery
channel the lincoln tunnel
yup all of these things that get you
easily in and out of
manhattan island yeah were built were
extremely expensive
and it took ridiculous amounts of
managerial power and manpower to build
yeah but these are caring minds but they
created it too the math and everything
these kids wake up one day and it's
there for them and they don't respect it
this is what life is like
yup it's just there i i you know i
remember you know like i'd be hanging
out
on like uh the lower east side of new
york by the river
and i'm looking up at the manhattan
bridge and i'm just like what would it
have been like if there was no bridge
there
who built this how much money like who
who who did all the labor and i think
back like
i was watching return of the living dead
you ever see that movie uh i think so
it's from the 80s
and it's like i don't know it's like
1984 bruce campbell
no no no return of the living dead is
just a zombie movie no i don't think
it's like it's a campy old 80 zombie
movie it's great i love it
i'm watching it and there's all of these
people doing things and i thought it was
funny because this is like a normal
human thing i was like
these people were making this movie
before i even existed like
a couple years before i existed
civilization was a thing
it's a funny concept because these
people don't understand that in their
minds it's true
it's true they don't realize we are all
standing on the shoulders of giants
we are sitting beneath the shade that
was planted by people who knew
they would never get to sit beneath that
shade yeah and that mentality is
is gone at least among these people
you're right you know it's
it's crazy i hope they come around
because we we can lose it
you know i forget who said it but we're
only one generation from
total annihilation basically if we if we
give up
and everyone just focuses on themselves
then who's gonna
who's gonna pick up the mantle i think
you know
one thing that really worries me is
this can't last forever this the way we
live
the chaos the politics we need survival
instincts
we need responsibility otherwise we will
not survive
that's true because we're not yet at the
point where we have replicators
we don't live in one of these wally
spaceships where everyone just floats
around a little hover chairs and they
gain weight all day because it's
everything's taken care of
we don't live there we really are
tricking ourselves into believing
we've conquered the world right and we
didn't yeah the fear of
not living is gone
because of the comforts that we now
provide everyone
as a baseline yeah you know there's no
fear of
i'm not gonna be able to my son
might not survive because my my house
might get burned down
or you know in a war like we don't see
wars
physical wars anymore like when was the
last time america
was in a physical war here good times
make soft
no one sees it here you know so that's
that's what i'm saying if we want to get
to that point where we do have a star
trek like future
yeah we have to have the the drive to
survive
but now we're losing it because people
think the game is over and we've won
right when we haven't no we're not so
that that brings me to this this fear
that
with a potential conflict with china
we're going to see mass casualties and i
mean mass as in
man you have not seen the level of death
that i worry about sometimes
yeah i don't know millions yeah you're
right
yeah millions of people maybe in the
event of like
we're really lucky but uh we haven't had
one of these great disasters of the past
because we really have done a great job
yeah solar flare well and when's the big
solar flare coming well i mean
right now the the sun is is relatively
dormant as far as solar flares go but
really you think about the societal
wheels that are moving around
that give everyone food we can go to the
store and buy food
if all that food suddenly you know if
the wheels stop
working to get them churning enough for
everyone to have
all of the stuff that they're used to
going out and buying
if all that disappeared right now we
would see
mass starvation bro and they will be
eating each other in the streets i know
and that that is a scary premise like to
think about it like we are
we could we've been down you know the
economy has been shut down for
five months now six months almost jeez
it's like
how are we how are we going to bounce
back it's not going to be a quick bounce
back
no you know and the food i'm not saying
it's gonna
i'm not saying it's guaranteed that it's
gonna be gone but
i've shopped lately and they don't have
a hundred percent of what they
used to have truckers don't wanna go
into cities that defund police and
you got that yep now if you're in a city
you got the truckers that are like i'm
not going in there i don't blame them
trucker's been pulled out of his trucks
and and beaten to death
i was talking to a cabbie a couple years
ago and
man it's crazy a couple years ago life
was just peachy and i mean whatever we
had the trunk it was still trump and the
media was crazy
yeah but it was like i remember exactly
what it was i was in new york
and i was talking about how like how
condensed the city is
and i was joking about how people don't
realize you know new york's
a crazy place to be if the world breaks
down and the cabbie was like man these
people come a couple days they'll eat
each other and drink each other's blood
and i started laughing and i'm like it's
right dude yeah they are if
like the tunnels get shut down or people
are the bridges are shut down or
something people are trapped in the city
they have nowhere to go
and there's no food what are they gonna
do
i'm i'm hearing an alex jones quote
in my oh what they'll eat their
neighbors yes and i'm i'm half
joking to be honest because i think most
people just leave the city but if you
you just said though if they
if they don't have a place to go and the
bridges are all shut down
they can't cross the bridge let's let's
say the bridges and everything's
they're fine because the bridges are
just roads
some of them have tolls all right let's
say this let's say right now
food stops coming into new york and the
water shuts off
everything's shut down you got two
million people on the island
what do they do well a lot of them are
going to get in their cars
the ones that have them many of them
don't and they're going to drive out of
the city
there's going to be mad traffic and then
people will eventually run out of gas
then you have a bunch of people walking
around looting and looking for food
within a few days the food is gone then
what happens
people will start fleeing the city in
random directions but they gotta eat
man you know what's really crazy think
about this war
when all of the troops and say like the
civil war the revolutionary war are
marching
through fields you gotta feed them
that's true how do you feel
how do you feed a group of you know
thousands of people who are like you
know in various areas walking around
food's got to be brought in yep people
got to eat
and they can go quite a bit you know a
long time without eating but maybe if
you're on a boat in the middle of the
ocean
they can't go that long without water
yep they still need to be supplied water
how does do you think anybody in new
york knows how to source water if the
water got shut off definitely not
nope definitely not and do you think
people are going to lay over and just be
like well i guess i'll die
no they're going to become ravenous dude
they're going to be like i will do
anything
peop like you ever you ever like not eat
for a while
and then finally whatever you ate tastes
just so good yep that's what's going to
be like these people are going to be
like desperately thirsty and hungry and
willing to do whatever it takes to not
die
jordan peterson talks about some
terrible things that have happened in
the past
that many people are like well that'll
never happen
you know and he talks about the
bolsheviks
and you know holiday more and stuff yeah
just in what happened back then
and he's like you never know what you're
capable of until you're
there and we are not there and most
people have no
idea how terrible it can be it's
it's shocking what he's talking about i
don't want to get
too crazy into details because it's
sickening thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you